product not yet rated
hey guys my name is Thomas cope I'm an
executive producer at CI games working
on Lords of the Fallen our action RPG
that's been in development since 2011
and it's going to come out this year on
PlayStation 4 Xbox one and PC
let's roam a little bit around old
monastery and in a meantime I'll tell
you about some crucial ideas that drive
the development of our game there's a
few combat encounters you will see here
focus around master and agile and so
I'll try to use lighter gear and
maneuver right for example trying to get
the perfect positioning and perfect
timing for an effective critical strike
it requires a little bit of practice but
is worth the effort
the world we set the game within is very
old and the legend has it that couple
thousand years ago people have fought
and successfully defeated their God
together with his demonic army and it
since then that they believe evil can be
completely cast away from human nature
each individual who commits a deadly sin
is forever marked with it - - across the
face becoming an outcast for entire life
anybody Harken our hero has a very dark
past behind him and because of that when
the demons or the 'roger as we call them
I started to reappear he is assigned to
face the threat it's almost as if people
believe that they can fight evil with
evil owned by the way it's worth
mentioning that we really put a lot of
work into highlighting the feeling of
intense do other than each single one
and one encounter that you will come
across here this next enemy normally
would not be much of a hassle because as
many attacked me from the distance but
surprise surprise there's a second one
so we gotten ourselves into more or less
a one versus two situation I want to be
extra efficient in situations like this
I always try to pull off a special dual
wielding combo with the daggers it
requires the timing but the dps is
definitely worth the try the game will
also unlock new worlds for you explore
once you advance on the story path but
the ones you just laughs are not locked
away from you it's not only possible but
also very encouraged to re-explore the
places you've already visited and new
areas will open up present me with new
loot in new paintings
all quiet here too
I'm not leaving without answers
this one here is a different type of
opponent
it's bigger stronger more aggressive but
also he's not defending himself so it'll
try a different type of timing with this
guy using a heavier gear since we're not
a slasher certain things will not work
like mashing the button for example
blocking well that probably won't get
you far in the long run so let's set the
pace right here I'll get in wait for
time to deal slower and stronger strike
then get out rinse and repeat
it's quite useful with heavy weapons
like this hammer and you can even charge
the attacks
okay let's jump straight into a boss
fight now this is gonna be the first
boss of the game becoming first warden
and we wanted him to resemble an
honorable Knights fighting and obeying
his demonic codex gameplay-wise our goal
was to mix action with RPG in a way
where all elements including story world
and characters revolve around the user
experience in our case that means combat
and character development
basically there are two main pillars of
combat in Lords of the following melee
fighting and magical supernatural skills
the first one is fairly tactical and
rewards players who like the feeling of
learning and the special sense of
becoming proficient at game mechanics
magical side of Lords combat on the
other hand even though it's not covered
in this video is designed to feel very
spectacular and powerful but that is
also not the only reward that comes with
using it our goal was to give players
the means to distribute the process of
learning how to play the game along the
time they choose you'll always be able
to use magic at times when the
difficulty spikes so it's up to you if
you want to use advanced strats instead
especially if that might get you a
better loop
there are three character classes that
you can choose from at the start of game
warrior cleric and rogue and they will
determine the set of spells that
manifest your playing style apart from
that the statistics of a character the
gear that you want to use can be
pre-mixed regardless of its suggest
class association for example if you're
more into heavy weapons but still want
to keep that light rogue armor there's
no reason not to try this combination
out or defensive play with a shield or
an offensive to weapon approach they
both can be mastered and become lethal
with enough skill and persistence the
last stage of the first warden fight is
where it gets interesting because we
finally managed to destroy the shield
making him a bit more vulnerable at the
same time we forced his aggression a
little bit over the edge if you remember
not to get greedy and deal too much
damage a too short amount of time you
can make it just please try to avoid his
special attack as it can stand lock you
and of course we wouldn't want that
would we
so that guys that's the first gameplay
for morons to fallen and of course
there's way more to come so keep your
eyes on our website and fun page we want
to make sure you know everything you
wish about our game before it gets to
your PlayStation 4 Xbox one and PC